MiG-29 Fulcrum.
Le MiG 29 ou Fulcrum, tel qu'il est désigné
au sein de l'OTAN,
est l'un des plus excitants chasseurs
que le monde ait jamais connu.
Développé pendant les années noires
de la guerre froide,
il est une des tentatives pour atteindre
le rêve soviétique d'obtenir la supériorité aérienne
dans n'importe quel conflit.
Heureusement, la glasnost a évité
qu'on en arrive là.
Il est l'un des meilleurs chasseurs actuels.
Ses capacités en termes de manœuvrabilité
et de stabilité à haute incidence,
en font une arme formidable.
Son développement a eu lieu de façon totalement
différente des habitudes soviétiques.
Contrairement à ce qu'on imagine,
la plupart des chasseurs soviétiques
avaient été conçus plutôt pour des missions défensives.
Le MiG-29 a été le premier avion soviétique conçu
spécifiquement pour des missions offensives,
comme défensives.
Pour bien comprendre les avancées technologiques
des chasseurs soviétiques,
construits par le bureau d'études Mikoyan
pour le MiG-29.
Il est nécessaire d'évoquer brièvement,
les 3 générations de chasseurs à réaction,
qui l'ont précédé.
La première génération, incarnée par le MiG-9
a été suivie par le terrible MiG-15,
qui fut modifié ensuite pour devenir le MiG-17.
Ensuite arriva le MiG-19
et ce qui est sans doute le plus célèbre
des chasseurs MiG, le MiG-21.
Bien que de grands progrès aient été
faits en aérodynamique.
La conception des chasseurs MiG resta la même,
jusqu'au MiG-21.
Les MiG-23 et 27 à géométrie variable,
ainsi que les MiG-25 et 31
constituent la 3ᵉ génération.
Pour la 4ᵉ génération de chasseurs,
les Soviétiques avaient besoin de concevoir
un avion capable de gagner les combats tournoyants.
Ce qui est la base de la supériorité aérienne.
Les connaisseurs savent que le combat tournoyant
survient après l'échec d'une attaque au missile
ou lorsque l'adversaire apparaît soudainement
à proximité.
L'occident avait des chasseurs de grandes qualités,
que le bureau Mikoyan devait égaler, voire surpasser.
La tâche du bureau Mikoyan avait
été définie sur cette base.
Mais après quelques années,
Mikoyan décida d'élargir un peu le projet
et d'incorporer dans la conception du nouvel avion,
les nombreuses innovations imaginées par ses ingénieurs.
Une grande partie de ces innovations
était révolutionnaire, pour l'époque,
en termes de technologie aéronautique.
Mais le bureau s'était fixé lui-même comme objectif
de développer un chasseur,
capable de détruire ces cibles à moyenne
et courte distance,
mais également aptes à engager les avions volants
à haute altitude.
Pouvant aussi voler à basse altitude,
pour s'abriter des radars
et être efficace de jour comme de nuit,
par tous les temps,
même en cas de guerre électronique intense.
Enfin, d'avoir la possibilité d'attaquer
des cibles au sol fixe, comme mobiles.
Le résultat, le MiG-29 dépassait de loin
les attentes soviétiques.
Le bureau d'études Mikoyan avait véritablement conçu
l'avion du futur.
Sa disposition aérodynamique fait que chaque partie
du fuselage et des ailes participent à la portance.
Lui permettant de figurer parmi les avions
les plus manœuvrant au monde.
En revanche, en dépit de toutes les innovations
qu'il intégrait,
le MiG-29 ne disposait que de commandes
de vol conventionnelles.
L'absence de la technologie des commandes
de vol électroniques,
avait pour corollaire de rendre le MiG-29
rapidement accessible à la majorité
des pilotes expérimentés sur les autres MiG.
Le cockpit comporte un pare-brise intégral
fixé au fuselage avec la partie centrale,
qui s'ouvre vers l'arrière.
Cet arrangement permet aux pilotes
d'avoir une excellente visibilité,
dans toutes les directions.
L'instrumentation est particulièrement complète,
permettant d'informer le pilote des statuts
de tous les systèmes de l'avion,
à n'importe quel moment.
Le pilote peut s'éjecter en tirant
l'une des deux poignées.
Le système automatique d'urgence,
éjecte la verrière dans un premier temps,
puis les fusées du siège propulsent le pilote
à bonne distance de l'avion.
La protection du pilote, du vent relatif
et de la pression, est assurée par la combinaison de vol
et par la stabilisation du siège
pendant la séquence d'éjection.
- Ce chasseur de 4ᵉ génération est facile à piloter.
Ces systèmes automatiques modernes
le rendent simple à utiliser.
Permettant de se concentrer
sur la réussite de la mission de combat.
De son système complexe de navigation
à la multiplicité de son armement.
C'est un avion richement équipé.
Pensé pour pouvoir remplir
une grande variété de missions.
Le pilote est pratiquement débarrassé
de nombreuses tâches,
grâce au système de contrôle automatique.
Il est également très fiable
avec ses nombreux systèmes redondants ou doublés.
C'est vital.
Il y a deux réacteurs.
Ils disposent chacun de leur entrée d'air.
Chaque réacteur est une turbine à double-flux
avec deux compresseurs à treize chambres,
postcombustion et une entrée d'air
mobile supersonique.
Les réacteurs peuvent être démarrés ensemble
ou indépendamment.
Une génératrice permet le redémarrage
du moteur en vol.
Ceci est assuré par un système installé
dans chaque moteur,
dans la chambre de combustion principale.
Les réacteurs sont installés sous le fuselage,
les rendant plus accessibles
et facilitant les opérations de dépose.
- Pour ceux qui mettent en service cet avion,
sa conception est parfaite.
Prenez le moteur, sa dépose
et le remontage d'un nouveau réacteur
ne prend que 45 minutes.
Il y a vraiment très peu de points de fixation.
La veine d'alimentation en air peut-être
démontée à part, très facilement,
et donner ainsi un accès très facile
aux parties principales du réacteur.
En plus, il est installé assez bas.
Du coup, Mikoyan a conçu ce système d'entrée
d'air de façon que pendant le roulage
et le décollage, ces panneaux se ferment
et l'air arrive par les orifices supérieurs,
protégeant ainsi les réacteurs de la poussière
ou d'éventuels débris.
Le train d'atterrissage tricycle
est constitué d'un train à vent
disposant de freins et de deux trains principaux,
chacun disposant d'une roue et de freins.
La rétraction et la sortie des deux trains
est simultanée.
Le train avant se rétracte vers l'arrière
et le train principal aussi.
Pour compléter le système de freinage,
un conteneur situé à l'arrière de l'avion
renferme un parachute de freinage,
contrôlé pour son déploiement
par un système électropneumatique.
En cas d'incendie, l'avion dispose d'extincteurs
dans les compartiments des systèmes et des moteurs.
Si le système détecte un feu,
tout le processus d'extinction est automatique.
Comme on peut le constater
sur ce décollage avorté.
- Cet avion est formidable par l'ingéniosité
de son aérodynamisme.
Il est solidement bâti avec une conception
intégralement aérodynamique.
Son fuselage peut supporter une charge très élevée,
mais pas autant que ses ailes.
Il est de fait très manœuvrable,
même sous facteur de charge important.
Il est conçu pour les combats aériens
à haute altitude,
lesquels demandent une manœuvrabilité extrême,
pour pouvoir en sortir vainqueur.
Le système de pilotage dispose des ailerons
pour le contrôle de l'inclinaison
et de stabilisateurs pour le contrôle en tangage
et pour la direction d'un palonnier.
En plus, l'avion a des becs de bord d'attaque,
des volets et des aérofreins directionnels.
Le système de commande de vol est constitué
de câbles de commande,
qui actionnent des vérins électriques
et hydrauliques.
La limitation des efforts sur le manche
et le palonnier se fait
grâce à des sensations artificielles,
créées par le système 3 axes de contrôle.
Le pilote est informé de l'incidence du moment
et des incidences possibles,
ainsi que du facteur de charge,
par un système de signaux de limitation.
Le contrôle de l'avion peut être manuel
ou automatique.
L'avion possède un système de ciblage à 3 canaux.
Le radar à l'abri dans le nez de l'avion
est conçu pour l'interception des cibles ennemies
de jour comme de nuit, par n'importe quel temps.
Il a une portée de détection de 100 km
et peut pister dix objectifs
et se verrouiller sur le plus dangereux.
Le système demeure opérationnel à 100%,
même en cas de brouillage radar intense.
Un détecteur infrarouge et un télé-détecteur laser
sont utilisés pour les cibles à moyenne distance.
Une fois la cible pointée par le détecteur à infrarouge,
le télémètre laser entre en action.
Ce système peut également détecter des cibles
situées derrière l'avion.
Une fois la cible identifiée et verrouillée,
l'arme la plus adaptée est sélectionnée pour le tir.
Missile air air moyenne portée
à guidage radar SEMI-ACTIF.
Missile air air lourd
à courte porté ou léger à guidage passif.
Rocket libre de 80 à 240 mm.
Bombes de divers modèles et masse
et un canon de 30 mm.
Le 3ᵉ système de visée utilise un système optique
et électronique très sophistiqué,
pour le combat aérien à courte distance
et le dogfight.
Le système d'acquisition est monté
dans le casque du pilote
et relaie toutes les données essentielles
du radar et des autres systèmes.
Tout participe à faire du MiG-29
une formidable machine de guerre.
Tous les MiG-29 sont construits
dans l'usine de Moscou,
qui utilise les mêmes techniques de production
que celles des usines occidentales.
- Le réservoir de carburant est au cœur
de la structure de l'avion.
Tout est fixé dessus.
Les ailes, le train d'atterrissage,
le nez et la queue.
Du coup, il est extrêmement solide.
Il est constitué de trois épaisseurs,
d'un composite très solide et néanmoins extensible,
comportant environ 130 m de lignes de soudure.
En raison de son rôle important,
il est rigoureusement testé aux rayons X
et magnétiquement,
pour éviter tout risque de fuite.
- Ce bâtiment abrite la ligne d'assemblage
du plus célèbre chasseur, le MiG-29.
Nos meilleurs ouvriers sont employés
à l'assemblage de l'avion.
Ici, nous installons les systèmes hydrauliques,
les circuits de carburant,
ainsi que les composants électroniques
et de radio.
En fait, tous les systèmes principaux de l'appareil.
Nous testons la qualité de tous les composants
qui sont intégrés dans l'avion.
Lorsque nous avons complété ces installations,
les représentants de l'aviation militaire
viennent pour valider notre travail,
avant que l'avion ne soit envoyé au centre d'essais
afin que les moteurs soient installés.
Chaque avion subit ensuite une série d'essais en vol,
avant d'être livré à l'aviation militaire.
- L'usine a dû être adaptée
à un nombre d'innovations de construction
qui ont finalement facilité
la construction du MiG-29.
Cependant, un MiG-29 est aujourd'hui
aussi facile à construire,
que les pilotes trouvent qu'il l'est à piloter.
L'avion est simple à entretenir.
Par exemple, il ne faut que 45 minutes
pour changer un moteur.
Certains avions de la même génération demandent
parfois jusqu'à 10 h pour la même opération.
Oui, le MiG-29 est véritablement d'une conception
très intelligente.
- À l'usine, nous avons reçu
de nombreuses félicitations pour le MiG-29,
aussi bien de pilotes russes,
que de pilotes étrangers.
Récemment, nous étions au Chili
pour le salon aéronautique
et les pilotes de ce pays et aussi du Brésil
nous ont dit qu'ils étaient le meilleur chasseur
sur lequel ils avaient volé
et le plus facile à piloter.
Un avion pour tout pilote.
La conception et la construction de l'avion
fait appel aux technologies occidentales
les plus récentes.
Une grande partie des éléments
sont faits de matériaux composites,
où la fibre de carbone est très présente.
D'autres éléments sont faits avec l'aluminium
le plus pur, de l'acier et du titane.
Souvent avec une structure en nid d'abeille,
Pour avoir une solidité maximum et un poids minimum.
En tout du début à la fin, la construction
d'un MiG-29 prend environ un mois.
L'usine produit une moyenne de 15 MiG
en même temps.
Les essais en vol du MiG-29
ont commencé dans les années 70.
Son vol inaugural a été effectué,
par le pilote d'essai Tuktor Abudu Kirov,
qui fit mieux que prouver la valeur des décisions
prises pour la conception de cet appareil.
En fait, les essais en vol, spécialement
quand l'avion fit ses preuves en vol à grande incidence,
montrèrent que les caractéristiques de vol étaient
bien meilleures que ne le prévoyaient
les calculs théoriques.
Les essais sont un processus continu.
De nombreuses modifications en vue d'améliorer
les performances ont été engagées
et en octobre 1977, les capacités de l'avion ont
été démontrée à Léonid Brejnev.
Mikoyan pensait déjà à de futurs développements
pour l'aviation russe.
Brejnev en fut impressionné.
À partir des années 80, les essais d'une version
navale utilisable depuis les nouveaux porte-avions,
classe Tbilissi commencèrent.
Le MiG-29, modifié avec des ailes repliables,
utilisa une rampe pour ses premiers essais.
Très rapidement, de vrais essais eurent lieu
sur le porte-avions,
par le pilote d'essai à Tuktor Abudu Kirov
et il fut réussi.
La Marine soviétique apprécia d'ajouter
à son arsenal,
un des chasseurs les plus performants au monde.
À la fin de 1989, plus de 700 MiG-29
avaient été livrés.
Pendant les années 80, il devint évident
pour le bureau d'études Mikoyan,
que le MiG-29, pour arriver au sommet de ses capacités,
exigeait des commandes de vol électroniques.
La nouvelle version équipée de ce système
fut appelée MiG-29M.
L'aérodynamique de l'avion avec son rapport
poids puissance supérieure à 1,
lui donnait d'excellente qualité manœuvrière.
La principale différence avec les versions originales
a été le déplacement du centre de gravité,
afin de modifier la stabilité.
En effet, comme tous les chasseurs modernes
utilisant la technologie Fly by Wire,
l'avion est naturellement instable, pour paradoxalement
lui donner une meilleure manœuvrabilité.
Le bureau Mikoyan équipa l'avion
avec des commandes digitales quadruplex.
Comme ces images le montrent,
certaines manœuvres réalisées par le MiG-29
ne sont possibles que grâce
aux commandes de vol électroniques.
Principalement, le calculateur quadruplex
empêche l'avion de décrocher,
ce qu'il ferait si le pilote
était seul aux commandes.
Un fantastique et impressionnant renversement.
Passage à basse vitesse et grande incidence.
Et enfin, grâce aux nouvelles commandes de vol,
le fameux Cobra.
Une manœuvre qu'on pensait infaisable.
- Les avions militaires russes étaient
traditionnellement plus manœuvrable,
plus stable et plus contrôlable
que leurs équivalents occidentaux.
Je ne peux pas en dire autant
de nos systèmes de contrôle.
Domaine dans lequel nous avons
souvent été en retard.
Mais en matière de construction de moteur,
de fiabilité, de manœuvrabilité
et enfin de solidité, nous avons sans aucun
doute atteint le plus haut niveau.
Les capacités du MiG-29 n'ont pas été testées
au cours d'un conflit majeur,
bien qu'il ait été en service avec l'aviation
irakienne, pendant la guerre du Golfe.
Un exemple typique de ses capacités de survie
a été démontré lorsqu'un avion
touché par un missile explosant au niveau
de la tuyère d'un réacteur,
parvint à rentrer à sa base.
Un bon exemple de ses capacités.
- En ce qui concerne l'avenir,
je dois dire qu'en ce moment,
on est tous un peu déçus.
Le MiG-29 a un potentiel qui n'a pas été exploité
encore à fond.
Et malheureusement, nous n'avons pas
pour l'instant les capacités financières
de poursuivre certains développements.
Toutes les études de développements sont
temporairement suspendues.
Ceci dit, l'avion possède encore un grand potentiel
et tous les professionnels se doivent
de reconnaître les qualités de ce magnifique avion.
La fin de la guerre froide, les deux superpuissances
ne sont plus des menaces l'une pour l'autre.
Nous avons été témoins de la fin de cette époque.
La course à l'armement n'est donc plus nécessaire.
Ceux qui ont été impliqués dans le développement
de l'armement, que ce soit des avions,
des blindés ou des navires,
ou de n'importe quelle autre arme,
ont perdu un marché immense.
Si le bureau Mikoyan veut rester dans le business,
il doit développer son réseau
de relations internationales avec d'autres bureaux
d'études et utiliser son talent évident
pour des avions peut-être à vocation commerciale.
L'industrie aérospatiale internationale
pourra alors bénéficier de l'expérience
du bureau d'études Mikoyan.
Le MiG-29 reste une preuve de leur excellent
travail en matière d'aérodynamique.
Il est peut-être le dernier
des grands chasseurs.